За кілька років Україна може зменшити
боргове навантаження до 50% ВВП, а за 5 років -
мати сильну економіку. У цьому переконаний
прем’єр-міністр Володимир Гройсман.
Чи справді є підстави на це сподіватися?
Сильною можна вважати економіку, яка
демонструє сприятливу динаміку
макроекономічних показників та має
високу стійкість до зовнішніх шоків.
Поточну динаміку можна аналізувати
за такими показниками, як темпи зростання ВВП,
рівень інфляції, дефіцит бюджету тощо.
Серед показників, які вказують на вразливість
до зовнішніх шоків, - зокрема залежність експорту
та імпорту від світових цін на сировинні товари,
високий тягар зовнішніх боргових виплат
та залежність фінансової системи
від коливань валютного курсу.
Якщо порівнювати Україну з іншими країнами,
що розвиваються, вже зараз вона показує
непогану динаміку,  констатують у Dragon Capital.
Реальний ВВП зростає декілька років поспіль,
інфляція знижується, кілька років поспіль
спостерігається помірний дефіцит бюджету:
нижче 3% ВВП.
Завдяки цьому почав знижуватися
державний борг у відсотках до ВВП.
На піку - у  2016 році - він становив 81%, а вже
до кінця цього року має наблизитися до 62%.
Це помітний прогрес, хоча показник
залишається вищим за середній для країн,
що розвиваються. Загалом він складає близько 50%.
Водночас, якщо аналізувати вразливість
української економіки до зовнішніх шоків,
то позитиву тут, як зазначають експерти, замало.
Економіка України залишається дуже залежною
від цін на сировинні товари: сталь, зерно, нафту, газ.
Окрім того, існує значне навантаження
щодо виплат державного боргу.
Іще одна слабкість -  інституції: регулювання ринків,
яке не створює рівні умови, а надає преференції
окремим групам, а також залежні суди, які
ухвалюють рішення на користь політичних
або фінансових інтересів, стверджують
економічні експерти . Відповідно,
для потужного зростання економіки в Україні
треба провести обіцяні реформи, щоб зробити її
більш привабливою для інвесторів.
Вкладники мають бачити, що країна рухається
вперед і змінюється на краще.
В іноземних фінансових інституціях не виключають
поступового зростання української економіки.
Приміром, у Світовому банку передбачають
зростання на рівні 3,5% наступного року.
У 2020-2021 роках зростання може перевищити 4%,
припускають в установі. Проте зазначають:
це можливо, якщо Києву вдасться впоратися
з кількома викликами. Серед них -
збільшення вартості продуктів, які Україна імпортує,
передусім енергоносіїв, та зменшення цін
на традиційний український експорт, а також
погашення боргових зобов’язань. До того ж,
окрім суто економічних ризиків, наступного року є й
політичні - президентські й парламентські вибори.
Це може означати більше популізму
і згортання реформ.
Отже, зважаючи на позитивну динаміку
останніх років, Україна може посилити економіку
у найближчі 5 років. Однак для цього
зростання має лишатися сталим, а це залежатиме
виключно від ефективного впровадження реформ,
наслідком яких має стати покращення умов
для ведення бізнесу. Це має привабити інвесторів,
які вкладатимуть гроші в українську економіку
і дадуть їй поштовх до розвитку.